- I'm here hanging with
Garret Hayden, give it up.
(audience cheers)
All right everybody, our next guest
sails the seven season style
as captain and star of the
hit show, "Below Deck".
The reunion airs this
coming Monday on Bravo.
Here's a look at that.
- That's the night of passion worth it.`
- If this show is just roasting me
like I'm living in log off.
- I think we do.`
- We're bullying.
- Bullying.
- I don't really know
what people were expecting
for me at that point.
- Compassion.
- I thought it was...
- [Man] Do you wish you
had let her go earlier?
- To top one, Eddie.
- Eddie, if you don't
actually think I'm stupid.
Do you?
- Oh.
Oh, dang (laughing)
That was a great clip.
Let's say hi to Captain Lee
Rosback everybody.
(upbeat music)
What's up man.
Meet Garret.
- Hi, there. How you doing?
- Garret, how are you doing?
- (laughing) I'm quite well.
- Oh my gosh.
That clip was hilarious.
And anytime you asked, when
you don't think I'm that stupid
like no one says anything
(laughing)
It's not a good sign, Captain Lee.
- Gotta think about that one purpose.
- It's not a good sign.
Well, Captain Lee fans
Below Deck call you the stud of the sea.
Do you like that nickname?
Do you wear it with pride?
- I find it rather embarrassing
but my wife Marianne gets a kitchen
an awful lot of mileage out of that.
- (laughing)
- I find stuff that totally irresistible.
- I love it.
- Never misses an
opportunity to poke the bear.
- That's a good relationship you have.
But what's the most
over the top thing that
you've seen on the boat?
Cause I imagine with a bunch
of crazy billionaires
that have so much money
they do some stupid stuff (laughing)
- You'd be surprised.
They really have.
They have, the innovation
level is really, really low.
They will just let it out.
- Wow.
- We had one woman, she was,
she was celebrating her 65th birthday
and her and her boyfriend had gone back
to the master state room.
And we hear this hollering.
She's hollering for the crew to come in.
So I don't know if
anything's wrong, so, but she
wants the whole crew.
So there's like six of us.
And we walked in.
There she is at 65 naked from the waist up
sitting on her board
straddling her boyfriend's lap.
He's a short little
front ball guy and let's
say whipped cream is involved.
- Oh.
- And she is,
yeah,
you can use your imagination
- Why was the crew in there.
- I don't want to use my imagination.
I want to take back that
you ever told me that.
- But she expected to happen yet.
Yeah. There's some
things you can't unseen.
That's one of them.
- What kind of person?
- I'm fine forever.
- Why, why, why
Why?
- I'll never looked the
whipped cream the same.
- She will not ruin whipped cream for me,
Captain Lee.
But she got a value and efforts.
People got too much money.
They got too much money.
You need to give some of your money away.
That is not okay.
- He was calling for help.
I don't know.
He might've been calling for help.
- Oh my God.
I'll tell you what if my neck
and behind it hurt myself and I'm naked
I would try and fix the issue before
calling people me in my room.
(laughing)
I'd be like, not can still
I'm like, you know (laughing)
I would cover something.
I mean, I ain't, nobody want to see that.
Oh my gosh.
Okay. Well, so that happens on the boat.
But yeah
there's no segue.
But I do.
I do think that their...
stuff gets serious as well.
And, I gotta ask you
in this kind of setting
because when stuff, crazy
stuff like that happens
and there's so many kind
of dynamics at play.
What made you feel
comfortable enough and want
to open up about your son's overdose?
Cause that's a huge thing like personally
and I'm just curious, like what
what made you feel like maybe I should
maybe I should address
it and talk about it.
- I think because nobody else was.
They have this stigma that's
attached to drug addiction
that they just label
addicts
with one paintbrush.
And it covers a wide swath
and addiction doesn't know any boundaries.
It doesn't know any social class.
It doesn't know whether you're broke,
whether you have a billion dollars,
and it doesn't really care.
And there's so many people that
are dying every day from it.
And somebody needs to, to bring it
to the forefront and try
to do something about it
which I'm working diligently towards.
Because it gets nowhere
near enough attention that it should.
And it's, it's painful to do
but if I don't do it,
who's going to do it.
And if I don't do it now, when.
- And honestly the reason why,
I mean, one of the main reason
I think it's so important
that you did bring it up is you're right.
It randomly, I actually
worked at a pharmacy.
I was a pharmacy
technician whenever I like
during high school or right
after, like before this.
And it was the saddest thing
in the world to see people come
in all the time, this
happened all the time.
All ages didn't matter, all
different walks of life.
They would come in
and they would try and
refill their prescriptions.
And you could see in the
computer that they had
filled them like for their pharmacies.
And I'm like, I can't give you more
you know, Oxycontin, I can't,
I can't refill this again.
And the thing is, is like
it could be as simple as like, you know
I found out one woman
had had a back injury
and then she just got addicted to it.
Like after that, she just got
addicted to stuff like that.
And it's , I think people
think they, like you said
they do one paint brush.
You think it's one type of
person it's it happens everywhere
in all walks of, I've literally
seen it with my own eyes.
And it's the saddest thing
ever, you know, to watch people
that when we know we're
near, you know, on that path.
And then one thing kind of happens
that domino effects into
other things and it's, and it
I feel like it's an epidemic.
I feel like it's a, it's a
really big deal in our country.
And like you said, we need to address it.
- It definitely is.
And people just have no concept.
I, until my son passed,
I had no idea
how many people that are
really affected and touched.
And people just came out of the woodwork.
I mean, tens of thousands of people
and they all have the same story.
- Yeah.
- And nobody's doing anything about it.
And that's the sad part.
- I agree with you.
And I'm, I'm so sorry.
Like it's the worst thing ever.
There's nothing you can ever say
to anybody who's lost a child.
I can't imagine it
but I do thank you from
the bottom of my heart
just for being open enough
to share something like that
to where maybe it can
help some other family not
lose their child.
That's what I think is
the most important thing,
you know.
- A lot of people live in denial.
They don't want to admit
that their son is a junkie.
- Yeah.
- They don't want to admit that
their daughter's an addict.
And so they'll rationalize
and that can be a deadly game to play.
- Absolutely. I agree.
Well, everybody, the
Below Deck reunion airs
this coming Monday on Bravo.